they marched from different directions
with one common demand
stop the repression
[Applause]
students artists trade unionists and
ordinary sri lankans united against a
government they say is stifling dissent
why are they arresting these people who
brought some kind of change i mean it
was a peaceful protest of the young
people
why are they arresting them for no
reason these scenes are what protesters
are angry about less than 24 hours after
president ronald vikrama singh was sworn
in replacing gotab rajapaksa who fled
the country military and police
commandos cleared the protest site
outside the presidential secretariat
since then the security forces have been
hunting prominent figures from the
four-month campaign that ousted
rajapaksa
i spoke out on behalf of the people i
also have a one and a half year old baby
this protester was arrested while trying
to fly out of the country
the head of the teachers union was
arrested at his office a few days later
even men in robes are not spared
this buddhist monk was arrested by plane
clothes officers a catholic priest is in
hiding
speaking after securing bail for another
prominent protester manoj nanyakara was
the police seems to be trying to fire
legal action one by one for some
political requirement but this has been
unsuccessful trying to repress the
protesters by taking such action is
futile what must be done is finding
solutions to the root causes of the
protests
his client who is released on bail
remains undeterred
justice will prevail so let's see this
is the fourth case so far let's see how
many more but we won't give up the fight
this struggle is for a system change and
we will continue the fight
but at the protest many told al jazeera
they won't let the crackdown stop them
we will not give up the struggle we
won't stop till we win we are telling
raniel rajapaksa very clearly we will
not be scared by your repression we will
only get stronger and stronger in
response to it
protesters say the government is trying
to silence them but they also say it
won't work
having got rid of one president they say
they won't be intimidated by his
replacement fernandez al jazeera colombo